To anyone who loves vintage fashion,
this is your reminder to be so,
so careful where you send things to go get cleaned or taken care of.
I have this beautiful vintage dress.
It's handmade, it's unlined,
and somehow it got in the regular dry cleaning pile,
and my husband took it to dry cleaning,
and now the entire bottom of the dress,
like, the hem,
came apart. You can kind of see where that line used to be.
So thankfully, it's not completely ruined,
but you can see, like,
look at all this fraying on the end of it.
I'm really hoping I can take it to a seamstress and get it rehemed
and hopefully get that all cleaned up.
But regular dry cleaners. Regular cleaners, like,
don't always really know how to handle things like vintage.
And the stitching is so delicate because it's so old,
that this is a shame on me kind of moment,
but hopefully one that will help you not potentially
ruin your favorite vintage garments.